Karin is with us in Reading Pennsylvania
hi Karen how are you great Dave how are
you better than I deserve what's up
first time I thank you because we really
appreciate your teachings we've learned
a ton and we we are not in debt and we
have money saved but we got burnt very
badly by a contractor which made us
spend our entire emergency fund and we
have investments but they're not growing
so we know we need to find a new
investment company but because we've
been burnt so badly we're not quite sure
what questions to ask of a new company
to make sure that we're not burnt by
somebody again it's a really good
question well the first thing that we
always tell people is is that you need
to remember that your investments are
your job but we will but we need the
counsel and the teaching of people that
are experts okay my estate plan is my
job but I don't know all there is know
about estate planning so I had to hire
an estate planning attorney okay
but since the estate plan is my job it's
not his job he has to tell me everything
we're doing and I have to understand it
or we're not going to do it because it's
not his job it's my job
you see the difference same thing with
your money it's your job and so you
can't ever say well my investment
advisor burnt me no you burnt you
because you let it happen
okay and so what that means is you have
to have an investment person or anytime
you're dealing with money people whether
they're mortgage or real estate or
investment or insurance or whatever that
has the heart of a teacher because your
job is to learn enough from them to make
good decisions you don't have to become
an expert in the in the I don't know I'm
not an expert in insurance but I know
enough about it to buy it intelligently
and I'm you know I could become an
expert on investments but you have to
know enough about it to buy it
intelligently to invest intelligently so
the that changes the job of the advisor
from babysitter to teacher you follow
the difference so you want that someone
then that has the heart of a teacher not
the heart of a Salesman when you sit
down with them if they've got the heart
of a Salesman you will leave
feeling like your arm was twisted and
dumber than when you went in if you got
if they've got the heart of a teacher
you won't feel the arm twisting and you
will leave they're going hey I actually
understand more about investing than I
did thirty minutes ago or an hour ago
and so you will know they have the heart
of a teacher in other words if you're
learning and if you're not learning get
away from them that's a big thing
because it's your job that opens up the
door to a whole lot of other stuff the
second thing I'm looking for if I'm
looking for someone to help me in a
money area of my life I want to know
that they substantially agree with my
money philosophies in your case your
money philosophies all right an example
is I don't believe in borrowing money so
I had this idiot CPA sit down with me
one time and he said you know I don't
agree with your stance on paying off
houses and that you know I'm not high
taking a tax deduction but we don't have
to agree on everything for me to do your
taxes and I thought yeah we kind of got
to agree on the basics and the fact that
that sucks and you can't add is so basic
I should probably want to agree with you
on and so you're not going to do my
taxes I wasn't mean to him but as soon
as he said that ridiculous comment he
was done in the interview to get to do
my work right because I want someone
handling my money that I have a general
agreement with how life works and money
works and so you know I don't have
people in my life that I have
substantial value systems disagreement
with okay and that waiting certainly
include the money piece and so in my
case you know I don't borrow money and
if the guys always want me to borrow
money then I don't need to talk to him
it's a guy gallon the businesses always
want trying to get me to borrow money
they think it's smart to borrow money
then you know they're dumb and I'm not
I'm not I don't need to be taking advice
from them and so in your case you don't
like that you told me that already and
so you know you need to ask your advisor
potential advisor how they feel about
that I think oh I hate that as a matter
of fact I've got everything paid off
including my house well you got somebody
that you have something in common with
then and they're going to give you
advice that's consistent with what you
value does that make sense
yeah that does and so you're looking for
those two things how much does it line
up and you know if you're following our
stuff exactly
are very very closely then you can just
say you know how do you feel about what
Dave Ramsey teaches because that kind of
kind of outlines what you believe you
know it's not that what I'm teaching
really needs to be the acid test but if
you agree with what I'm teaching and
you're living that way then it would be
your acid test because it's now become
your way of living not my way of living
is that make sense
yes very much so so you want your value
system to align and you want your
audience particularly your money value
system to align and you know if they
think well charitable giving is
ridiculous or all religion is a hoax and
anybody that gives money to the church
is a fool and if they think that well
then they're not I'm a Christian they're
not going to be my financial adviser
because I obviously do believe in God
and I obviously do give money to my
local church and and if they think
people to give money their local church
or a fool and they think I'm a fool once
so I don't need to be their customer you
know and I certainly don't want their
advice on anything you follow me so
that's the kind of thing you're looking
for and there are people in the
investment world that believe that and
that's okay that's okay they can't
believe that I'm not mad at them but
they're not going to be my adviser so
that's why we put together the smart
Wester program when you click on smart
Wester at our website it gives you a
list of financial advisors in your area
financial mutual fund brokers in your
area and you can select from that list
the thing we have vetted them for is
first and foremost do they have the
heart of a teacher and secondly do they
have you know a clean code of conduct
which that's a fairly easy thing to vet
in that world they're not crooks in
other words not visibly anyway and we
vet them very carefully on all of that
and and then generally who wants to buy
an endorsement from Dave Ramsey well
people that kind of believe like Dave
Ramsey hello you know and so if they
believe Act if they think I'm an idiot
then why would they buy an endorsement
be one of our smart mister probes so
you're generally going to find somebody
that lines up with and goes along with
you know the wide spots in the road of
our investing advice I certainly allowed
to have their own opinions and things
like that but we vet them for that and
so when you go to a smart Wester Pro you
know you're you know you're kind of
going to get those things but the big
thing for us is do they have
heart of a teacher or they just
slickster you know is it just Slick
Willy selling mutual funds and you just
don't want that you know you don't want
to slickster and there's people around
in that business that are that way so 85
percent of people in the financial world
are taught how to sell they're not
taught what to sell and they don't even
know what they're doing a lot of them
they're good hearted but they're just
dumb and but they're really good at
selling and you know you get screwed a
lot more by somebody that's an
enthusiastic ignoramus then you will buy
somebody's a con artist you know I
remember one time I was I was in my 20s
and I was enthusiastic ignoramus I
selling stuff I know what I was doing
but I just believed I just oh yeah yeah
go get do this I was just wrong and you
know I mean I actually sold the guy a
house three weeks after I turned
eighteen years old like that's my real
estate license sold the miles the next
week who buys a house from an 18 year
old I mean that was dumb you know cuz I
was I was dumber than a rock man I could
barely draw up the papers and I'm yet I
wasn't representing this poor guy he
didn't get messed over thank goodness I
didn't do something stupid but I wasn't
cause I knew I didn't know anything I
couldn't hardly find my way through the
front door what are you talking about
and yet I'm in out there mr. enthusiasm
my disco clothes on selling houses right
and can you imagine David 18 years old
with with disco clothes and hair showing
houses oh my lord
God don't think about that it'll burn
your eyes out hey guys Rachael Cruz here
hope you enjoyed that video from the
Dave Ramsey show if you want to watch
another great video check out my video
three things you should consider renting
right over here or click the link in the
description below